[Music]
not too long ago I received a letter
from a fan in South Korea named sunny
Lee this is real she wrote that she was
watching clips of me on YouTube instead
of instead of studying for the Korean
SATs and she wrote me letters two of
them actually on her SAT test sheet
she instead of actually studying she
wrote me this long very nice letter she
wrote me a version in English and she
wrote me a second version which is in
Korean just in case yeah just in case I
only speak Korean and she also was kind
enough to send me there's a giant box of
Korean snacks I was excited about that
until my assistant immediately ate them
yeah so they're gone now
good hold so now yeah got to my Korean
snacks well anyway very kind letters and
based on this fantastic letter I decided
to visit sunny Lee in her country of
South Korea I'm going next week and then
we'll air a special show based on my
visit after I returned because ladies
and gentlemen here is my motto and I
want this to get out all around the
world if you send me free snacks from
your country I will travel there in
person to thank you that's what I do
wasn't that a great clip subscribed to
my youtube channel for an endless supply
of me
[Laughter]